[Music]
hi my name is greg alba and i'm john
humphrey and we're with the real rejects
um
hi thank you both so much uh for taking
the time every day to talk with us um
when this was first announced we were so
excited for it and then we watched the
trailer and it looked great and then we
saw the first episode from the very
first episode we were like this is
exactly what we wanted it to be so like
the green come through it ultimately
delivers and i mean that in the most
sincere way uh very very much excited
for audiences to actually check this out
in more ways that you realize my first
question and i guess we'll start with
james on this one but pinacco i would
love for you to answer as well uh we're
only a few episodes in for for our
viewing experience and already we want
an anime star wars movie and i think a
lot of people are gonna want that too is
there any episode where you are
considering trying to expand it into a
feature film or have there been any
talks about a feature film in the anime
style wow that's a that's a great
question um
right now there has not been any there's
not an episode that we'd say let's
expand this episode in particular i
think we'd love to expand all of the
episodes are a good deal of them i think
what i think that's really cool about
them is they're all so rich in the sense
that like it feels like the life going
on outside of that slice of life that
you get to see in the storytelling so no
has there been conversations about star
wars feature in anime oh gosh that would
be so cool i i i think we we're all huge
anime fans i mean that's really the
impetus of this project you know we
wanted to do something like this for a
long time how do you do it what's the
right approach d-plus gave us an amazing
opportunity to say like okay we can
let's do something different with star
wars let's try things differently so
that's where this came from
you know never say never uh there's
certainly people um including myself
that would love something like that to
happen but currently there's nothing in
the works
i really feel like that after this show
there's going to be a big demand for it
undoubtedly yeah
so i i guess kanako if you want to take
this next one away and then james if you
want to weigh in uh i think one of the
best benefits of the series and one of
the coolest parts is that you don't have
to be so beholden to the established
canon but that being said were there any
major characters or classic characters
that you wanted to toy with or better
yet are there any of the characters
introduced in visions that you would
love to see transition into the canon to
the live action or anything like that
um the patient's idea originally started
from like is like asking studios to
bring their own characters to the star
wars universe so some video i think you
might you already seen touching rhapsody
yes
you did so there's existing characters
there um but we essentially ask them to
like please explore your own like
imaginations and then like bring the
original characters in the star wars
galaxy so
yeah it would be great to see existing
characters in anime format but like for
this particular vision uh project like
we asked them to make original
characters and i hope like everyone
would fall in love with these like
unique characters
that the studios made
i feel like from the twin duels episode
the people already everyone i talked to
cannot stop talking about those two
characters already yeah
and um obviously you know can't give any
spoilers but i'm curious just from both
of you is there any particular episode
that you are most emotionally drawn
towards yourself or found to be your
particular favorite yeah i mean
again it seems easy to say they're all
special in their own way we love all our
children say it away
but but i think like the thing that's
really special about all these is that
they have star wars values and star wars
dna
inside all of them and what i mean by
that is like take something like
tattooing rhapsody that uh is really a
story about fountain family right it's a
there's nothing more star wars than that
i mean from from rebels to to the
original trilogy on it's about in new
trilogy it's about the idea of finding a
family
you know and following dreams and and so
like those fundamental like mythic star
wars themes are so woven into so many of
these that they feel right they feel
real uh they're all kind of touching in
that star wars way i think
it's so hard i know ride is really
touching and unlike anything you will
ever see
tattooing rhapsody
we all dream to be rock stars uh me
included one day that will happen
and
you know i mean happy not falling up
that kind of dreamer uh story so
i don't know well
those stories they all stick out but
those in particular i don't know they
they they all they're full of heart
kanako
yeah it's very difficult to pick
one but if i have to say something and
so as much as the movies i was wondering
like what other people like what other
people's life would look like so from
that perspective i loved i was very
delighted to see a story like village
right to introduce like uh people living
in their own ritual and next
in in the outer rim and lopino is also
about the planet tower so it's like very
like a different introducing like a new
um
people or
aliens aren't you thinking
introducing like how people live in the
star wars galaxy and then and something
you've never seen before so that is a
very uh something i was looking for and
so i'm glad to see like uh some creators
explore that in their shorts
that's great to hear those are really
great answers guys thank you
thank you very much for that we were
actually talking before you might ask
them about like it's called visions
right yeah what what inspired that that
title of visions i mean it's very broad
but also is there something more
specific that we're missing we were like
googling trying to be like why is this
called visions exactly so yeah for sure
i i mean
we needed we we really wanted to find a
framework that would unlock
the best way to do star wars and anime
and what i mean by that is we didn't
want to approach each of these studios
with uh
a point of view from us and say this is
the story that we really are hoping just
to get your aesthetic style right
really wanted was to really lean into
their imaginations and unique cultural
com perspectives and come from and what
each different studio brings
and so to do that i think we realized
very quickly the answer was make this a
celebration of star wars and like kind
of like the elements that influence
these people these different creators
and so we needed a framework that would
allow for that not not like legends is
very clearly like our former eu content
we needed something that was going to
say
you know go experiment go have fun go
tell an authentic star wars story but
in your unique medium
there was an old book that came out
sometime early 2000s called star wars
visions and what it was was this amazing
art book where george and the team
rinsler and all the team back then
essentially
went and hired some of the world's best
artists and just said you know do your
interpretation of star wars
and i remember looking at that
and we were looking for a name that
encapsulated what we wanted to do at the
time but it was like such a joy to look
at that and see like what each of these
individual creators brought to star wars
and we realized that's essentially what
we're doing here
so this is such a great
you know
easy understandable way uh of course and
so that's the origins of it obviously
this vision is very different than those
humble roots but sure sure i i think
that's really cool how it works it works
in like a meta level yeah in so many
ways
um before we go there's something i've
just got to ask to both of you really
quick just a super quick answer age-old
debate age old debate when this was
announced and that prompts the last
question we'll start with kanako
subs or dubs which one do you prefer
i have to say subs okay all right
bose have a very like both actor has
their own interpretation towards the
character so i hope everyone enjoyed
both version watch japanese original and
english sub dubs
enjoy like a two different like yeah
languages
get two different viewings out of it and
james yourself
i like that i i what why does there have
to be war here let's be hard we can have
fun you know what you're doing
[Laughter]
you get it
you can going to get something different
from each experience is the truth we've
got an amazing uh dub cast the original
cast is is clearly the original vision
in the original intent
both are really cool experiences
absolutely absolutely
thank you both so much for your time
it's been an absolute pleasure and i
really can't wait for star wars fans to
see this because i think you're going to
get a huge demand for more i i just
fully suspected fully suspected thank
you guys so much take care thank you
[Music]